YURI GRINSHTEYN: As you look
to make your services more
reliable and easier
to operate, logging
becomes increasingly important,
both during normal operation
and troubleshooting.
Today, I'm here
to show you what's
new in Google Cloud Logging
and help you get started.
This is the Stack Doctor.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We've looked at logging errors
in the previous episode,
but Cloud Logging has gotten
a major update since then.
The Logs Viewer is entirely new,
and there are new capabilities
under the hood.
Let's take a look.
You can access the logs
in your cloud project
by going to the Products
menu and selecting
Logging under Operations.
This will bring you
to the Logs Viewer.
Note that you can pin
products in the menu
so that they're always
at the top of the list.
Logging is probably one
of the ones I use most.
The new Logs Viewer has
three main sections.
The Query Builder
at the top is what
you use to filter the
logs in your project
to just the entries you need.
The Query Results at the
bottom shows you all the log
entries that match your query.
The Histogram view
in the middle shows
you the volume of logs that
match your query over time.
This is incredibly useful
if, for example, you
were looking to understand
when a particular error started
happening.
There are two primary
ways to create queries
against your logs.
The first one is use
the menu selections.
The second is to write
the query directly.
Let's take a look at both.
First, you can use the menu
selection in the Query Builder
to select the resource, log
type, and log entry severity
that you'd like to
include in your query.
You can make your selections
as granular or as broad
as you like.
The Query Builder
will then generate
the string query for you
based on your selections.
Your second option is to
write the query directly
without using the
menu selectors.
This may become easier
and faster for you
once you've spent some time
using the Query Builder.
We've also published
a library of queries
you can use to get started.
We'll link to that below.
Note that this new Logs Viewer
is still in a preview stage.
This means that lots of features
are still being developed.
One of these that's only
available in the classic Logs
Viewer is the ability to
save and share queries.
This is incredibly valuable
when working with teammates.
You've now seen how to view
and query logs in your project,
but how do logs
actually get there?
Let's take a look
under the hood.
The Cloud Logging API
is the external endpoint
that serves as the single
entry point for sending
logs to Cloud Logging.
No matter where logs
are coming from,
whether it's from a logging
agent installed on a compute
VM, your application running
in GKE or App Engine,
or any of the Google
Cloud services,
they're all sent
to the Logging API.
The API sends log
entries to a Log Router.
This is the internal
plumbing that
determines what happens to
log entries that it receives.
The Log Router
evaluates each entry
to determine whether
it meets the filter
criteria for any exclusions.
If an exclusion is applicable,
that entry is discarded.
That's not the case?
The entry is stored in
the Cloud Logging back end
and is then
available to BigQuery
through the logs of your
or for log-based metrics.
The Log Router also
evaluates each entry
that it receives to determine
whether it should be exported
to a downstream destination.
You can configure exports to
Cloud Storage for archiving,
BigQuery for
analytics, or Pub/Sub
to send logs to third party
or event processing systems.
Note that the exclusion
and the export evaluations
happen in parallel on
the same log entry.
That means you can both export
log entries and exclude them.
This can often be used to
great effect to save costs.
Thanks for joining me today.
We looked at the new
Logs Viewer and learned
how to build log queries.
We also took a
look under the hood
and learned about how
the Log Router works
to allow you to precisely
control which logs are stored,
discarded, or exported.
That's it for this episode.
Come back soon for more.
This is the Stack Doctor.
Stay healthy out there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]